un estudiante aprende que los compuestos
iónicos tienen un carácter covalente
significativo cuando un camión tiene un
efecto polarizador en una unión grande
ok de qué estamos hablando
bueno si tenemos un camión este es
nuestro ocasión y por acá tenemos una
unión muy grande
mejor no era de otra forma porque un
camión tiene electrones vamos a ver aquí
tenemos el núcleo del camión y tenemos
una nube de electrones pero como tenemos
menos electrones que protones tenemos
una carga positiva y por eso se le
conoce como catión y el avión tiene un
núcleo positivo y tiene una nube de
electrones pero voy a dibujar una unión
grande aquí tenemos una unión muy grande
y esta es la nube de electrones pero
como tiene más electrones en la nube que
protones en el núcleo tiene una carga
negativa este es el año
año ahora nos dicen que tiene un
carácter covalente significativo cuando
un camión tiene un efecto polarizador en
un año grande entonces una forma de
verlo es que estos electrones que están
por aquí se quieren alejar de sus amigos
negativos porque las cargas negativas se
repele y quieren pasar más tiempo cerca
del cateo así que empiezan a tener un
carácter covalente entonces aquí tenemos
un efecto polarizador porque estos
electrones pasan más tiempo del lado
izquierdo que del lado derecho así que
tendremos más electrones y más carga
negativa de este lado que de éste eso es
lo que nos están diciendo
ahora como resultado el estudiante
plantea la hipótesis de que las sales
compuestas por cationes pequeños
ian iones grandes tienen puntos de
fusión relativamente bajos bueno se
necesita menos energía para romper esa
estructura cuando se encuentran en
estado sólido seleccionados compuestos
de la tabla y explica como los datos
sustentan la hipótesis del estudiante
vamos a ver todos estos compuestos son
sales que al disociar se si pensamos en
los cationes que obtendríamos podemos
decir que los cationes los cationes que
conforman estos compuestos son
litio
sodio
sodio y potasio y los aviones los
cañones que conforman estos compuestos
son yoduro yoduro y fluoruro no
escribiré al revés fluoruro y yoduro ok
y cuál es pequeño y cuál es grande bueno
primero vamos a comparar al litio sodio
y potasio vamos a ver aquí tenemos al
litio sodio y potasio todos forman parte
del grupo uno de los elementos y
conforme bajamos en la tabla periódica
se agregan capas electrónicas así que el
tamaño aumenta entonces el tamaño
aumenta conforme bajamos en la tabla
periódica el tamaño aumenta
y por lo tanto de todos estos el litio
es el más pequeño y el potasio es el más
grande entonces vamos a escribir litio
es el más pequeño
más pequeño
y potasio es el más grande de estos tres
más grande
ahora si analizamos los añón es el
fluoruro y el yoduro se encuentran en el
mismo grupo y como el yoduro está más
abajo tiene más electrones agregamos más
capas electrónicas así que el yoduro es
más grande que el fluoruro entonces el
yoduro
es más grande y el fluoruro es más
pequeño entonces miren el yoduro de
litio es un caso en donde tenemos un
camión pequeño y una unión grande ese es
el mejor ejemplo de lo que está
planteando el estudiante un camión
pequeño y un año grande y de hecho tiene
el punto de fusión más bajo de todos los
compuestos de la tabla ok ahora vamos
con el otro extremo que pasa si elegimos
un camión muy grande y un avión pequeño
bueno aquí no tenemos esa combinación
pero si tomamos el cloruro de sodio
si el cloruro de sodio se ve interesante
en este caso tenemos un camión más
grande y este es un avión pequeño grande
y pequeña
pequeño y observen que este compuesto
tiene el punto de fusión más alto
entonces estos son los dos compuestos
que vamos a comparar inciso a comparamos
comparamos yoduro de litio que tiene un
catión pequeño
un camión pequeño más un avión grande
un cañón grande
con el fluoruro de sodio que tiene un
cateo en grande
una unión pequeño
y observamos observamos
que sus puntos de fusión
puntos de fusión son consistentes
son consistentes con la hipótesis
el punto de fusión del yoduro de litio y
el punto de fusión
del yoduro de litio que es el compuesto
que tiene el camión más pequeño
menor de hecho es mucho menor que el
punto de fusión del fluoruro de sodio
que el punto de fusión
del fluoruro de sodio entonces si
comparamos estos dos el compuesto con el
cat ión pequeño
coincide completamente con lo que el
estudiante está diciendo al tener un
punto de fusión más bajo y al analizar
el punto de fusión más alto aquí tenemos
un catión grande y una unión pequeña así
que todo esto es consistente con la
hipótesis del estudiante ok
inciso b identifica un compuesto de la
tabla que se pueda disolver en agua para
producir una solución básica escribe la
ecuación iónica neta de la reacción que
provoca que la solución sea básica bueno
pensemos en cómo podemos formar una
solución básica para eso necesitamos
tomar algunos hidrógenos de las
moléculas de agua para así formar el
hidróxido y bueno aquí tenemos algunos
candidatos que pueden hacer eso porque
tenemos todos estos saludos como el yodo
y el fluoruro pero por ejemplo
duros de hidrógeno o ácido clorhídrico
es un ácido fuerte entonces el hache y
ácido cítrico es un ácido fuerte
fuerte mientras que el ácido
fluorhídrico es un ácido tv'
te vi entonces un ácido fuerte no será
muy bueno para tomar hidrógenos porque
más bien lo que quiere es tener sus
hidrógenos desesperadamente así que el
yoduro no es muy buen candidato pero el
ácido clorhídrico es muy interesante
tomemos uno de estos candidatos podemos
usar el fluoruro de litio o el fluoruro
de sodio tomemos el continuamos con el
cloruro de sodio entonces si tenemos
fluoruro de sodio y nos piden que
escribamos la ecuación iónica neta de la
reacción que provoca que la solución sea
básica bueno entonces seleccionamos el
fluoruro de sodio
esta es la primera parte identificamos
un compuesto que se puede disolver en
agua para producir una solución básica
ahora primero hagamos la ecuación iónica
y después pasemos a la ecuación iónica
neta entonces si disolvemos esto en agua
tendremos cationes de sodio disueltos en
solución acuosa más uniones de flúor
también disueltos en solución acuosa y
eso estará en equilibrio con
mejor lo pondré de otra forma mas h2o
porque eso es con lo que están
reaccionando y aquí no escribimos en
solución acuosa porque esta es la
solución a clase y ahora si esto estará
en equilibrio con
voy a pasar este texto hacia abajo para
que no se corte la reacción en dos filas
entonces esto está en equilibrio con
vamos a ver este flúor tomar a un
hidrógeno entonces tenemos ácido
fluorhídrico hf en solución acuosa más o
h menos también en solución acuosa y aún
tenemos el cat ión de sodio en solución
acuosa ok esto se encuentra en
equilibrio y tendremos hidróxido en la
solución estamos formando la solución
básica ahora si esto fuera el ión yoduro
la reacción tendería hacia esta
dirección porque si esto fuera yoduro de
hidrógeno esto no estaría en equilibrio
porque éste sería un ácido fuerte que
definitivamente querría deshacerse de
sus hidrógenos por eso es que no usamos
yoduro de hidrógeno y preferimos el
ácido fluorhídrico si estuviera en
estado gaseoso sería mejor llamarlo
oruro de hidrógeno pero al ponerlo en
solución acuosa lo consideramos ácido
fluorhídrico bueno y entonces en la
ecuación iónica neta no tenemos que
preocuparnos mucho por el sodio porque
se encuentra en los dos lados así que
sólo nos enfocamos en esta parte esta es
la ecuación iónica neta